you say there's no global contagion from
Argentina but it is part of the wall
array that investors face why does the
Argentine default whether SP says it's a
faulted or Argentina claims and didn't
it matter for markets and for investors
well I mean it matters for markets and
investors first of all this morning
we're gonna see is to meet to decide
whether there was a failure to pay and
whether there for a CD s that represent
over a notional billion dollars of our
gin teen debt have been triggered which
by the way our Argentina's already the
world's most expensive sovereign debt to
ensure and so that would that would end
up being somewhat problematic certainly
for the country to some degree for its
trade partners I don't think globally it
really has much impact that said it
really is occurring in and already
faltering an economy in a already
faltering region and I think it's just
adding fuel to the fire of concern give
us some context here because we talked
about how Argentina has not been part of
the global capital markets for thirteen
years now what is it missing out by not
having access to that foreign capital
well over the past five years they've
left about fifty billion dollars of
foreign direct investment on the table
if they were at foreign direct
investment levels equal to their peers
by not paying the settlements and having
access to global capital markets they've
lost over the next ten years probably
around seventy billion dollars to GDP at
a time seventy billion at a time where
GDP is already faltering in fact GDP is
going to contract for the first time
since 2002 this year
debt to GDP has increased since 2011
from about forty two percent so
relatively low to over forty five
percent and this is gonna get far worse
you got to remember that not only will
the debt to GDP number rise as as the
debt levels rise but also as gdp falls
they've got a real issue here that
ultimately if it's not cured will put
them back on the path to a nineteen
eighty nine ninety one style crisis
which is not the default crisis
that's where internal debt caused them
in nineteen eighty nine to devalue by 50
and a half percent in in July and other
thirty five percent in discharge I got
it I got to stop you for a minute you
may
is de the International Securities
Dealers Association meeting today
determine whether it was a default the
Supreme Court has already said Elliott
associates Elliott management is due
money that money wasn't paid
how could there possibly be any
conclusion other than default well I
find that hard to believe and hard to
understand as well especially when you
read the language language says
bondholders the exchange bondholders
have not been paid until the money is in
their pockets and it clearly hasn't been
because it's a Bank of New York Mellon
so it seems to me pretty clear as well
okay let me bring up a chart here this
is yardage on Tinian peso is just one
indication of the trauma for Argentina
this goes back 20 years stability ugly
then really ugly that's not logarithmic
Spence wouldn't let me do a log chart
Friday Michael Spencer's were the
Solorio Ken Rogoff once wrote a
monograph for the IMF with 14 types of
floating currencies is Argentina part of
the international system or are they so
outside of it we can separate them from
any potential contagion no no I think
they're there in the system it you know
not completely but but they haven't
they're not completely disconnected
people are investing there other Latin
American countries are investing there
important country companies are located
there like Mikado Libre to the bay kind
of Amazon of Latin America it so they're
no they're not disconnected what they
are is going off on the wrong course in
terms of economic show IMF step in here
as they have many times before no I
don't think so I mean it you know
there's no fundamental basis for an
agreement right now you know Argentina
has to turn around and move in a
different direction before the IMF has a
way to to help out Josh help us out here
as we look out until next week what is
the single that you'll be watching for
that could make things worse before they
get better
well first of all we're gonna watch
these two judgments and I think that's
important second if they don't sit down
and negotiate a settlement within the
next 60 days you're gonna trigger the
cross default clause which ultimately
could lead to an acceleration on
payments to those 93 percent who did
take Bart action in those agreements
which were
about the entire foreign reserves of the
central bank and then beyond that I
think we've got other significant
problems because ironically the exchange
bondholder clauses from o5 in 2010 also
have the same party passu language okay
that was included in the suits that
Elliot and others won so I think we
could end up with a whole new round of
litigation by the other 93% if they
don't cure quickly
it sounds ugly doesn't it does sound
ugly then again it also sounded ugly
when we were talking Greece and we got
through that so hang in Greece decided
to be part of a solution and really
worked with creditors we've seen the
exact opposite behavior belligerence
yeah but it's still remember it's still
small why Greece it's not going to
destabilize the global system